it's getting hot in here so take off all
your clothes
it was going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings today
I'm joined by Mike gaps can find him on
Uncle Buck Tuesdays on ABC yes sir
survivors remorse yes always doing the
stand-up thing always doing the stand-up
thing staying busy huh I'm staying busy
are you ready to eat these wings are you
hungry my name is chicken wing Wow
there's a comedian named chicken wing
yeah from Queens yo chicken are you
ready to do this let's do the after the
chicken
this first one is sriracha no big deal
huh so you used to work at a Waffle
House and Ponderosa steakhouse right
yeah
you know when the pretty girls come
there and I didn't want them to know
that I worked at Waffle House I run in
the back you credit your comedy career
to not being able to hold a job at those
places right why do you think you were
such a terrible restaurant employee I
got caught stealing waffles one night
right after work that was one reason I
wanted to do something for the kids in
the community so I took a box of waffles
out of there and the camera caught me
trying to play Robin Hood johnabroad
Robin Hood Waffle House is always an
interesting place to me because it seems
to draw celebrities and droves but then
at the same time when you see crazy
headlines like somebody drove their
pickup truck through the front door to
like confront a waitress like some
ex-boyfriend it's always at Waffle House
a lot of restaurants are closed Waffle
House stays open 24 hours like you said
it attracts any and everybody from the
low to the high and they got like a lady
just standing there and every after you
give her your other order she's just
standing there so I want to scattered
covered smothered I want to is oatmeal
cut and the dude is just
he's just cooking while she's saying
this man good uh pretty good so on Uncle
Buck you play one of these uncle's who's
like a good uncle but also kind of a bad
uncle so I'm hoping I can just bounce
some sort of coming of age life moments
and you could give me advice as the good
uncle bad uncle's yeah all right I have
a crush on a girl in my third period
biology class but I don't know how to
tell her just write it on a piece of
paper do you like me yes or no think of
the classics I can't go 30 seconds
without scrolling my phone
throw that window go get ahold chirp
phone take him back go get a beeper I'm
getting bullied online because I'm a
fully grown man and all I have is this
ridiculous hot wing show on YouTube you
don't flame me groom leave them kids
alone get a real job
get real
these won't be hot they're getting there
everybody early in the show is like
they're always like what is this I came
here to eat hot wings but these aren't
hot just what I'm doing really do
anything me I'm scared of you chalo how
are you doing so blah and then everybody
always faces that back 9 mm here so you
take up all your bones you also play an
uncle on survivor's remorse yeah so if
this Uncle Buck things takes off I
really think that you have the potential
to be the greatest fictional uncle of
all time of all time I want to bounce
five greats off of you and you can tell
me what you thought of these great
fictional uncle first one Uncle Jesse I
like Uncle Jesse he was too young to be
uncle somebody put him in a bad
situation if I was a young kid um I say
Uncle Jesse you got a bag or I could use
cuz I'm an unusual kid
Uncle Phil kind of look like Suge Knight
but different sensibilities thank God
Uncle Sam oh I don't want to see him at
all not a fan of Uncle Sam not a fan and
whoever's doing his perm need to cut it
Uncle Fester oh man
I say Uncle Fester you look like a
molester and number five uncle Luke
uncle Luke
what I would bring to him is I was asked
hunka Luke how can I get Hey hey mo a
kind of a throng as a cook God you've
been in music videos almost as long as
you've been in movies and they run the
gamut from nori to Kendrick Lamar yeah
and then your mixtapes kind of run as
deep as DJ dramas yeah I wonder how does
hanging out with rappers in the studio
compared to just shooting a ship with
comedians backstage at the Comedy Cellar
man when you hang out backstage with a
rapper it's a hundred guys back there
our girls and then when you hang out
with convenience it's real cool
everybody back here cracking jokes
waiting to go up you know like night and
day night and day there that difference
it is different man
trapezes man it might be a gun back
there
of all the music video sets you've been
on whose was the most fun I gotta say
Kendrick Lamar Kendrick Lamar yeah cuz
we're just dancing in the middle of a
field next to a casket that sounds let's
I don't know if that sounds like such a
great it was fun but it was just crazy
this is our hot sauce we're very proud
of it
homeboys hot sauces heat inist I think
it's the best hot sauce ever made but
I'll leave it up to you I'll do it so
you're playing Richard Pryor yeah I
wonder how did diving into Richard
Pryor's character change Mike Epps as a
person preparing to do this role and I
thought read about Richard Pryor said
wow I'm a church kiyah compared to him
he was really really layered up this guy
was really really smart really really
crazy and uh I just realized I'm not
that crazy
yeah I got a chance yeah now is where
the game starts to kind of get serious
so I think the Richard Pryor
conversation segue is kind of into this
one you know your Netflix specials know
hold something go ahead
definitely I recommend it a little bit
of a kick on that one damn
hey yeah go ahead
your Netflix special it's called don't
take it personal as someone who's done
stand-up comedy for 20-plus years I
think that you're the perfect person to
ask do you think that audiences are more
easily offended in 2016 than they say
we're in the 90s not really you know
2016 you got the Internet peoples all on
it and that they doing everything on
internet so I don't think people get
offended as well as much as they would
be in the 90s really it's shocking in
the nineties to hear somebody saying
different stuff but now it's like oh man
I seen craziest stuff on the internet
seven pain 100% all the way through not
90 not 80 100 it's a man wing right
there mmm man that's hot not good with
hot [ __ ] don't ways is too hot man I
can't even talk you're kind of you
seemed in a confident place in the first
couple of wings and now my eyes is
watering my lower back is hurting I
can't taste it I can't taste my tongue
damn tapping out ah I'm done man I can't
do them up
nothing to stop here but I can't not to
admit like I answer your questions but
will the opting your wings
and the way you're dressed my guess is
you got a day of press today I do all
right all right we'll let you sit it out
because we don't want you sweating under
the lights all day long I might have to
get a ton cash out to death well I'm
gonna keep eating the wings if you're
still good with the conversation will
you you can tap out so the other thing
we like is we like to show you know some
pictures from Instagram because you have
these great pictures but they're void of
context so just wonder what's going on
in some of these looks like you're on a
kayak and this one yeah I did a little
kayaking one done you can't really see
it but there's three midgets in the back
of me holding you down in this one
you're backstage at WrestleMania there
you are with John Cena yeah it was
really fun
so you seen a guy walk past and look
booty shorts on the last one this is a
crazy picture you DMX Cam Newton do we
have the Bojangles Bojangles chicken
DMX brought some Bojangles backstage and
one of my shows see Cam Newton got his
Arkell pants on that's quite the scene
and I got the bubble guns now you worked
with Mike Tyson unmeet the blacks
what were your conversations like what
sorts of stories did he tell man Mike
Tyson it was tough
I'll see how they look here felt with
that gorilla now good job - wait there's
one more thing I guess I could eat going
on don't eat this one this that same
paddle principle what my ass with it and
they had chicken wings on it you know
when our young talented people go to
make a career in show business usually
they go to either New York or Los
Angeles but you took a greyhound to let
Lana how quickly until you realized you
know what maybe I should have gone to a
coast real quick
I just realized only way I could get
famous now is don't want some money get
some holes how do you make a name for
yourself in the strip club you just
bring a lot of cash a lot of cash you
just
all one's till you get all the way down
to the bottom there's one money order
bet if I die out of money or the back
huh how do you think Atlanta compares to
say LA or New York Atlanta is uh you
know
Hotlanta they call it Hotlanta and you
know the DJ is just sitting there
telling everybody to tip the strippers
but he's calling them hoes [ __ ] it's
like y'all better tip these old tip
these [ __ ]
y'all better throw these thought some
dollars and then la it's like that's why
fellas coming to the stage she goes by
the name of I chili hog whines there's a
woman come out with a little thin thong
just dangling ever seen a baggy thong no
no but I don't think I want to yeah it's
pretty ugly what about New York is New
York different yeah New York is really
rough girls sitting there dancing is you
got a old book and bullet stuck in at I
got shot at melly-mel con 1381 all right
so this is the last wig I think I've
ever told you if I blow man on the Lord
of the Rings and Spiegel you look better
than him Jesus Christ I'm into the
meanest thing anyone's ever said to me
related to him that's like Goblin
Smeagol the Goblin that's like my brush
that [ __ ] that thing he has nice eyes
have you ever looked at his eyes he's
got a really good green are you kidding
no you don't look exactly like him but
you guys are related that's not better
okay you don't look like a man good I'll
give you can't take it with me you
thought it you're giving me a compliment
call yeah okay guys that as like Smokey
Robinson come on give me a good green
ass man what the hell you want me to say
you're one of instagrams great
motivational speakers yeah maybe after I
take this last way you give something
motivational something inspiring for the
future Gus so that maybe they can
get through it you know that me do for
the future guests the decide they want
to come on this show and eat some wings
go vegan yeah go vegan cuz this chicken
is hot it's hot the devil won't eat this
[ __ ] that's my motivational speaker and
fellas brush your teeth before you
suckle girls titty Mike you made it
through the all right yeah actually
didn't mike you didn't make it through
but you know what we're a forgiving
place here at hot ones let the people
know what you have going on in your life
hey this is Mike s make sure you check
me out on huncle buck June 14 is Mike
Epps I'm gonna Instagram F see the real
Mike Epps on Twitter the real Mike Epps
on Facebook make sure you follow me make
sure you do the right thing and if
you're drinking and driving pull over
and have sips
you